Daniel see in fort lauderdale florida
you're on the bench Groeschel go for
Daniel hey I had a question for you
regarding the left almost promotion of
these riots not so much the protests I
definitely separate the protesters from
the rioters
I think processing is one of the
beautiful rights we have this country
and I from I encourage it but I'm almost
curious they're promoting these riots
now I wonder if they were able to
implement their socialist utopia if they
would feel the same about rioting at
that point I think I know the answer to
that but I want to hear your thoughts
also what do you think would be
different if they were able to enact
their socialist utopia what do you think
they would do differently when it comes
to riots and protesting um well I mean
if they were able to enact their
socialist utopia they'd run over the
riders and the protesters with tanks I
mean isn't that what happens in
socialist utopias i Tiananmen Square
didn't happen in a capitalist free
country it happened in a communist
country the fact is that socialism is
all fun and games until somebody decides
they don't like the system at which
point the state runs directly over them
socialist countries are not exactly
famous for their tolerance of public
protest and I'm not talking about
capitalist countries like Norway I'm
talking about full-on socialist
countries like the ones that that that
the the hard left actually espouses the
venezuela's of the world they're not
they're not really fond of counter
protesting again you can sit by the way
you can see this in in how they've been
treating in a soft way the the anti
lockdown protests if you're an anti
lockdown protester they've been using
the full force and weight of the
government to shut you down and try to
prosecute you if you go and try and open
your business today in New Jersey Phil
Murphy will come to your business and
shut you down if you try to do a minyan
in New York City bill de blasio will
show up pounding on your door but if
you're out there by the tens of
thousands marching and shouting George
Floyd's name and spitting all over each
other then it's fully okay so yeah I
mean it's fairly obvious that if you
protest in a way the Socialists don't
like they are perfectly happy to use all
the government power to shut you down
and if you protest in a way they do like
they're perfectly willing to waive basic
common sense and decency and her to let
you do it it's pretty incredible Daniel
really appreciate the call Brad and
Alice around the bend Schapiro go for
bread hey man I got a question about
abortion so I consider myself a
conservative and I would think that if
your first smaller government and the
government having less power
and one you want the government to not
be able to tell you whether you could or
could not aboard your unborn baby
regardless of the moral and ethical
implications of it Thanks and the basic
answer here Brad is no because the
fundamental idea of conservatism and
even libertarianism is that the
government does have a role in
protecting human life and so the
question is what the definition of human
life is if you believe that that's a
human life in the womb then the
government has a role in protecting that
human life just as the government would
have a role in protecting you from being
shot in the face right the government
would have a role in protecting you at
the 9-month in your mother's room in
your mother's womb from being chopped
apart and sucked into a saying that is
the basic libertarian and conservative
idea on abortion Brad appreciate the
call John in New York you're on the
bench bureau Shilo for John 7 so my
question has to do with convincing
people to change their mind I'm sure you
know one of the hardest parts of being a
conservative is convincing someone on
the left to change their mind and that's
kind of the point of the movie Inception
correct they need to have an awakening
moment and come to this agreement with
themselves in order to believe the
information that you are exposing to
them so my question for you is that if
you were in a position let's say one day
you were the future president or in a
position where the left-wing media had
to pay attention to you and would listen
to what you had to say how would you go
about changing your message so that
people would actually research the facts
and try to learn for themselves to
change their own opinion instead of just
sharing all these gotcha videos on
Facebook that never actually get
anything done because all you're really
doing is sharing those videos with your
friends that share the same opinions of
you and the people that need to see
those videos never actually get to see
them yeah I mean Sean I think there's a
lot to that on social media I mean
social media tends to be a place of
silos and I don't think social media is
where you tend to convince people you
tennen convince people in face-to-face
conversations and the way that you
convince people is by starting from
shared premises so very often people
start from sort of the the wrong level
of the conversation so if you start
let's let's take this this whole protest
situation as an example if you start
from the premise we all agree police
brutality and racism are bad and now the
question is do you think that defunding
the police is a good idea well we're
starting from the edge of the police
that police brutality and racism are
and that we don't want black people to
die now we can have a conversation about
the ramifications what you're talking
about but what people like to do is they
have an argument about a policy because
they don't want to have the argument at
the underlying level because they
actually want to exacerbate the
disagreement so you have to start from
shared premises and then you can sort of
have a decent conversation because the
baseline assumption is that we're all
decent people here we all sort of agree
on the fundamentals if you don't agree
on the fundamentals by the way then it's
possible you can't convince anybody in
the conversation is over but it's good
to know that right at the outset John
appreciate the call Ian in Oregon you're
on the bench presser Californian I have
two questions regarding current events
sort of from a legal standpoint the
first one is in Georgia it appears that
the gentleman who fired the last shot
used a racial epithet after he fired
after he shot him do you think
manslaughter is off the table now you
know I think that it is unlikely that
they will charge I mean that I believe
they've already charged them with murder
I think the manslaughter is probably off
the table because again the level of
premeditation required material felony
murder who's committing a felony and
trying to apprehend somebody who had not
committed a crime so that's kidnapping
so if you kill somebody in the middle of
a kidnapping then that's a felony murder
um it could theoretically be a
manslaughter as you say once you use the
racial epithet then it looks a lot like
you were stalking this guy to at least
try and stop him with the gun on a
racial basis murder charges are
definitely on the table there I think
that manslaughter is very unlikely
charged there I think manslaughter
frankly is a better charge in the case
of Derek Shelvin based on the sort of
split autopsies and the fact that it
doesn't appear he was trying to kill
George Floyd he was doing something
wrong he's doing something brutal but I
don't think that he wanted George Floyd
to die I don't see a lot of evidence of
that but again we'll see what a jury is
willing to decide on that I think
manslaughter best fits the description
in that particular case but that's not
the way the prosecutors are going I
appreciate the call David in Hollister
California on the bench Pierre go for
David question here so with obviously
what's going on right now the big thing
is defunding the food and with the
defunding of the police what is your
opinion or what do you think is going to
be the next step after they define the
policeman who's gonna be picking up the
not on one call who's going to be doing
the investigations any suffocation
yeah anything on you David I appreciate
the call they they literally have no
I mean it spoke people from Minneapolis
were asked this question and they said
that they need to check their privilege
if they're worried about it the answer
is they have no idea because again this
is just virtue signaling bullcrap that's
all this is
all right it will continue to bring you
the latest in a chaotic and unfolding
time you're listening to the Ben Shapiro
show